I'm Michelle fields with reason TV today
Emily Ekins is joining us from the
reason foundation to discuss the recent
results of the reason route poll thank
you so much for joining us good to be
with you so reason has just released the
results of their second reason route
poll what is the reason route poll well
the reason route poll is part of a new
public opinion project here at the
reason foundation where we're exploring
attitudes towards governments can you
tell us a little bit about how the poll
was conducted yes we surveyed about
1,200 adults age 18 and over throughout
the u.s. we called them on landline and
mobile phones and the margin of error
for this polls about 3 percentage points
and what do you think is the most
interesting or most surprising thing
that you learned from the results well
to GOP presidential contenders
definitely stood out in this poll we
asked of those who were going to be
voting in the GOP primary who they would
most like to see when the nomination and
Mitt Romney and Rick Perry were
neck-and-neck at about twenty percent so
this is definitely interesting since
Rick Perry the very new entrant to the
field so Ron Paul lost narrowly to
michele bachmann an iowa straw poll was
this reflected in your poll we actually
found something very interesting with
ron paul and michelle bachman in our
survey they both pulled at about seven
and a half percent roughly equal which
is similar to the to the aim straw poll
in Iowa where Ron Paul only lost by
about a hundred and fifty two votes to
michele bachmann so this tells us a few
things one is that we know that with
straw polls Ron Paul is king of the
straw poll he wins draw polls and so we
could you knows people could argue that
the aim straw poll was not really that
interesting because you know maybe his
supporters just were disproportionately
represented there but with this
nationwide survey we're not cherry
picking people these this is just a
nationally representative survey and we
still see them neck-and-neck at about
the same but the same percentage points
how did President Obama do in full it
depends it didn't look really good for
President Obama about 48
said they disapprove of his job
performance as president with about
forty six percent saying they do approve
so it's pretty evenly divided between
those who are happy and those who are
unhappy with his job performance but I
would say almost more importantly the
disapproval is with Congress eighty
percent said that they are not happy
with the way things are going in
Congress well Republicans and Democrats
are the ones who make up the majority of
Congress do you see any hope for a third
party candidate well again that depends
there's a couple of things that might
point us in that direction first is we
know that we noticed that the most
likely responds when people were asked
what political party they identify with
was to say they're an independent
thirty-eight percent that I'm not going
to choose a political party now of
course most of those independents have a
pretty consistent partisan preference
but there's a reason why they're
choosing to not identify with the
political party and say they're
independent and we actually asked
specifically about a very unconventional
type of presidential candidate asking
would you support a presidential
candidate who identified as economically
conservative but also socially liberal
and nearly half said yes that they would
favor that kind of presidential
candidate so all of those things point
to people being open-minded about the
kinds of presidential candidates they're
willing to consider did you ask any
open-ended questions regarding who they
would support in 2012 yes we allowed
them to volunteer any candidate they
would like to see be President or run
for president in 2012 and you know of
course we got a good five percent of
people saying themselves but a few
interesting things point stuck out one
was that about seven percent said they
would like Hillary Clinton to run for
president we also saw a showing for
chris Christie he actually garnered more
votes than john huntsman who is
clared presidential candidate in this
race what does the pole tell us about
the current political landscape that's a
really interesting question and
typically in most polls people ask you
know how do you self-identify your
political views are you a liberal or are
you a conservative so we we do have the
Liberals and the Conservatives that are
economically and socially liberal and
economically and socially conservative
but they actually only make up about
twenty-eight percent each respectively
we've got two other groups though one is
a kind of a small government group kind
of a group of libertarian leaners these
are people who want small government
when it comes to economic issues and
small government when it comes to social
issues as well and they make up about a
quarter of the political electorate the
fourth group we could call
communitarians there are people who
would prefer government to be involved
both in economic and social issues as
well thank you so much for talking to me
thanks for having me I'm Michelle fields
from reason TV